what is going on there reject nation we
have friends who are in this auditorium
right now we have a private watch party
to go watch venom let there be carnage
thank you to cinemark for hooking this
one up this is a movie we all really
want to see full disclaimer john and i
haven't seen it coy has seen this twice
already but i was like koi you got to be
here with us love coming to cinemark i
really love just the ambiance of this
whole theater and i think that they've
been so generous to us that i'm i'm now
a loyal
cinematic patron no matter what even if
it wasn't gifted to us i'd be paying top
dollar to come here that's love
but i respect them enough to keep the
mask on for this intro all right we're
gonna give her honest thoughts right
when the movie's done let's go guys
pretend like we're gonna walk directly
to there without checking the footage in
slow-mo
[Music]
we just got out of venom let there be
carnage
[Laughter]
quick reactions in just a little bit why
don't you one of you guys go first
let me let me preface because i've seen
it before and let me preface that uh
greg's experience right now was my first
experience i actually called greg and i
was like hey i just saw a movie
and i need to comprehend it for a little
bit because it's a cacophonous
experience it is a whirlwind of light
and sound and that is what hurt
symbiotes so we experienced the the
venom but i do think it's a movie that
upon rewatch gets better each time and i
think what you need to know going into
the movie is which kind of film you're
getting i think the best way to keep the
bubble of comic book movies from
bursting is to diversify your content
and no matter what as much as you have a
space opera with guardians and a heist
film with ant-man and these epic scopes
they are a certain tone with marvel
they're they're very varied in their
tone but you can still say like that's a
marvel film whereas this is not and i
think that's a really beautiful way to
go like hey that insanity couldn't exist
over there let's dance and i personally
like that we get a diversified version
of content so nothing feels stale if you
go full ganzo i respect the gonzo
personally did you talk about the movie
or something else
that's how i feel about venom it's a lot
of things
it's a it's a life experience really to
be it's about like the life foundation
okay look here's what i like about it i
think tom hardy steals the show once
again i think he was absolutely
entertaining as hell to watch from
beginning to end and i like the dynamic
that they form with him that they tease
here in the trailer where they really
have formed this like codependent toxic
butting at heads like they really double
down on like oh there was kind of like a
bromance like actual romance going on
between them let's like really double
down on the fives there and i enjoyed
that a lot of it is intentionally funny
a lot of it is unintentionally funny and
there's also some really cool effects
here with carnage for sure the movie
itself
uh it's it's you know you you said when
it was done you're like it was a weird
movie and i was like
yeah
maybe koi's just
saying he's a weird guy and then you
watch and i kind of think i know what
they were going for with here because
you recommended reading maximum cards
before watching this and so i read
maximum carnage over the weekend and i
was like this does feel like a comic
book movie here's what it also feels
like it feels like those like early
2000s comic book movies that we're still
figuring out how to do comic book movies
like a better version of that but it
still feels that way if in case you
haven't heard this movie is like 35
minutes all right the runtime is
remarkably short honestly here's my my
basic consensus is that there's a better
edited version out there i feel like an
hour and 45 times about two hours yeah i
feel like
it's shot really well and there's a lot
of fun things they're dealing with here
and clearly tom hardy's having a blast
and they have a lot that they're wanting
to explore and i think in terms of hero
versus villain yes does it improve upon
the first one absolutely it's just that
you can you can't help but for me at
least it is entertaining it is cheesy
and i'm not just saying that i'd be
honest with you guys if i hated the
movie because i didn't i got i thought
it was really fun and you can see why
that seems to be the passing grade for
this film because that's what it seems
like the final edit of this movie is
setting out to be but i can also get
this sense that there's this commitment
from the actors and the director that
there's a more i don't know if the right
word is heavier but i'm still getting
that better flesh
that hits better that would like a
little bit of like a dark weight to it
it kind of felt like it was holding back
at times on the kind of movie it really
could have been so i feel like in some
ways we are reviewing the first venom
movie like
but i would say but it's not the same
kind of movie it's totally weird yeah
it's way weirder yeah it's like the
people that love the lobster tank scene
will love this like this movie is the
lobster tank longer let's talk a little
bit more i'll let you know if i
recommend it or not john yeah i thought
this was a very strange experience isn't
it
a very fun experience as well one that
it's a lot like the first venom in the
things i have to say it's like yeah tom
hardy and venom are the heart and soul
of the movie there are some great
supporting characters especially stephen
graham i thought he was pretty great he
was probably my favorite just actor
supporting character he was acting his
ass off
one of my favorite rappers got a
prolonged cameo that was exciting for me
to behold yeah moreover i felt like this
did yeah embrace a certain gleeful
cacophony that at times does feel like
it's a bit of a mess at times you can
tell a lot like the first movie that
certain things were probably trimmed
down or perhaps tamed so as to maintain
that pg-13 rating but the action's a lot
better it is always fun whether it seems
like it's intending to be fun or whether
it's being campy and kooky um and so
yeah in a way it does feel like a very
unique albeit early 2000s-esque like if
a sam raimi spider-man movie got right
it was good yeah it wasn't as smooth or
as good and was crammed into a smaller
box than it was designed to fit in but
ultimately
it comes out as this unruly and
ultimately endearing
mess but that's really fun to behold let
me be more succinct can someone judge my
last friend i think that it is like a
universal monster movie with a lot of
saturday morning cartoon flavor in a
very good way with a dash of 90s comics
to me this feels like watching something
that doesn't have all of the gravitas of
needing to be the most important thing
it's a good time and it's here for a
short time and it's a whole whirlwind
the movie and i think that they intended
to make that so to me the comedy was
much more intentional to me the action
was a lot better to me they they used
these archetypes to really just throw
the spaghetti at the wall and see what
stuck and most of it stuck for me and as
a kid that grew up reading carnage
carnage looks better than i ever could
dream carnage looks incredible he looks
like a ryan stegman piece come to life
he's got the skeletalness he's got this
almost inhuman nature so you've got like
a an almost todd mcfarlane venom mixed
with a very very ryan stegman carnage so
the dichotomy of that is stunning to
watch and you've got michelle williams
having a blast like i think she had way
more fun because she knew she was way
more i mean i think like even with the
dan character what i'll say is that i
think it does succeed in capturing from
like reading maximum carnage capturing
the cheesy gleeful menace
from those from both carnage and venom i
think it does to see that and i think in
terms of adapting i like personally what
they did more with the shriek and
carnage relationship what they imbued in
the setup for them much better than what
they do in the comments oh yeah i think
it's a lot cleaner it makes it yeah it
makes it work a lot better i also think
if you're looking at comic book movies
and if you want to use spiderman because
it's a very linear path to spider-man
the sam rainey film has the best world
like jonah supporting cast he's in new
york it all feels like spider-man and
then the second set with andrew garfield
that's the best in universe spider-man
like the comedy from spider-man's better
all those things about spider-man are
better but then the last one the most
recent one i think tom holland's best
peter parker i would say venom here is
one specific archetype of what venom can
be they might make another venom movie
in like 10 years with a new cast a new
world and you can do that because he's
an archetypal character and i think
we've got just one type of venom we're
not talking about topher we've got one
type of venom we should be we should
talk about but i think this is like the
sam rainey this is the a little bit
kitschier a little bit more silvery this
is the beginning and we might get a
garfield down the line or holland but i
like this i actually really enjoyed the
way they have a advanced and added on
towards the relationship with talk with
uh eddie brock and venom specifically in
this movie like venom is he's pretty
funny in this film which is exactly what
you would expect but i think venom's
funnier in the comics that people
remember yeah he's weird he talks to
himself he makes jokes and laughs at
himself everybody's like i'm serious
like don't worry about it he's
experienced so much carnage
they're both like just they they they
talk a lot and eddie before he gets shut
up
he like mutters to himself working out
people forget how weird the 80s comics
were and then they watched the first
movie like that's not venom like no
that's exactly that oh yeah there's
different types of elements i think it
succeeds at what it's set up today yeah
i think i think for the most part it
does succeed to set up what it did you
like it more than the first one i did i
and i liked the first and i was one of
the few defenders the first loudly
but i think this is is much more of what
it set out to be versus the first ones
felt like three films two of which kind
of matched one that was like hey and
like kind of like was often its own
thing i don't feel like we've nailed the
venom movie yet but i feel like this
movie gets us closer it has all these
elements that yeah if they all breathed
to the degree i hope they all could have
then yeah we would have like it gives me
hope that maybe the third one can nail
all this fun stuff they're clearly good
at clinch that last couple feet yes yes
some kind of bonding to these characters
beyond being endeared by the fun i
honestly could see what they were going
for and that's why i was thinking i feel
like there's just a better edited movie
in here that was it it's like there's
some parts are just a little bit choppy
but for the most part
yeah i'd say i'd say it's fine
satisfied i didn't walk away
disappointed or anything i was like yeah
this is about what i expected and it's
weirder than what i thought it would be
even you were trying to prep i tried you
were trying to remember me for how weird
it is because i want you to have that
audience yeah and i i won't go into what
makes it so weird other than like like
obviously you could pick up some cues
that like totally some of this seems
like it's a mishmash of a bunch of
different things does that always equate
to an eclectic fluid translation not
always but
some of that weirdness you're like i
don't know why
this could be considered really bad or
this could just be very entertaining and
i can't tell sometimes this is
intentional or not but for the most part
i feel like they're just setting out to
entertain and they're they're doing just
that i've seen it three times because
that's considered tom hardy's love of
venom in the top 10 of actors playing
comic book characters the guy's
passionate about the character he loves
it he gets it if you listen to his
interviews he is so invested in eddie
brock venom in their relationship so to
me that's well worth the time the price
of admission etc this movie is eddie and
venom's movie and then carnage is fun
too but it's it's a it's just fun it's
great
okay we just realized we shot this whole
review without even talking once about
the post-credits team because i feel
like that's all anyone's talking about
with this is stay for the post criticism
stay for the post credit scene we wanted
to just talk about the movie
specifically then we ended this video
without you
because you don't need to stay for the
scene nothing happened
it's just a ferris bueller fine but yeah
i mean i i have the strongest
inclination that people will be talking
more
about the post-credits scene
than they will be talking about the
movie itself and yeah it's a
it's it's a good post-credits scene the
best one sony has done
before it i would argue can't be
overhyped like if you've heard oh my god
you're not even ready there's nothing
that can really quantify what it is it's
really engaging it does build on the
world it does
build out uh the future but it also is
totally appropriate i think it really
does a great job with what it is and
still being a part of the movie while
being absolutely insane yep it's a post
credit scene it is the first credit
scene and it does exactly what you think
those things are supposed to do you're
gonna watch a movie you're gonna watch
credits you're gonna watch this see the
posters
then you're gonna go home well it looks
like we're all on the
same from moderately to high
recommendation value
no matter what we say all right guys
leave your thoughts down below corey
thanks for being here cool yeah i got to
interview the cast there's some weird
interviews those guys are great check
those out and also let's capture some of
the reactions that people saw the movie
with us jaby kawaii what did you think
of venom let there be carnage i had fun
i really really like the relationship
between eddie and venom and that's about
it everything else in the movie was not
good to me the important part is i came
out with a smile what would you think of
the post credit scene right because
that's all everyone cares about oh that
was awesome courtney achara what'd you
think i had a lot of fun with it i
really like the relationship between
eddie and venom and yeah i just enjoyed
it it's a fun movie was i expecting like
oscar material no but i had a good time
i agree i came in ready to kind of be
underwhelmed because the first one
it was okay this one was way better i
had a really good time with this eddie
and venom had a much stronger
relationship carnage was okay but i did
have a good time chris what do you think
buddy oh it was it was short it was fun
and they definitely embraced the humor
in this movie it just took it to a whole
nother level there it was it was it was
fun tara tarawari tara tara what'd you
think i don't know i mean do i have to
it i mean it was fine it was fun it was
funny sort of could have been better
first one i didn't like say this one
better
[Laughter]
hi this is really close
uh movie it was fun better than the
first one uh by a lot i like venom a lot
as a character so i feel like for them
to not give me what i want but double
down on what they wanted i respected
them for that i'll watch whatever
they're gonna do next and that after set
credit scene was wild um
literally the most direct way of doing
things i can't talk about but yeah aaron
olivia what'd you guys think be honest
honestly it's okay i guess
i think if you saw the first this would
set your expectations up like i don't
think the first is a good movie and i
don't think this is a good movie but i
think the first set me up to experience
that this is not going to be a good
movie
but it will be a fun movie and it is fun
but it's it's not it was fun but the
post credits scene uh kind of left me
with a big smile on my face to be honest
that's the only reason you should go
watch this movie
thank you guys then thank you cindy mark
um yeah we saw the movie hell yeah
thanks